the twins are handing the ball to danny
cool
it's his first career start but he's got
plenty of experience he's been pitching
on a relief in saint paul and he's done
a very good job so far
hit to left field deep to the corner
chased by arise and
a fair ball catch a rise into a slide
makes a great catch to start the ball
game
not a lot of experience in the outfield
but not a lot of experience and all our
foul ground in this ballpark down the
left-field line and this ball looks like
it would have ended up
fair and
hangs on deals with the wall slides in
and just a great play right there to
start the game that'll bring up ahmed
rosario
he is truly the opener is ahmed rosario
crushes the ball into the bleachers in
left field and the indians will play
from in front as they take a one-nothing
lead
that's the way you stop it over 16 slump
with a no doubt about a laser shot his
fifth home run of the year boy and
now you know why he throws curveball
more than he does his fastball because
rosario hits his fifth and
he knew it that was a vicious line drive
and that was out in a hurry
a little topper slowly hit and it's
misplayed
and then safely is rosario to keep the
inning alive
there goes
rosario the throw down is not nearly in
time i think he almost picked off the
pitcher with that throw bobby walked
scored a run
picked up an rbi last night on a ground
out
bobby sends a fly ball deep center field
back goes gordon looking up it is gone
to straight away central
oh a big blast off the bat of bobby
bradley a two out two run homer and it's
a big three run first for cleveland he
went straight away center watch him keep
his hands back and
i mean that was dead middle of the plate
and that's what you should do with a
pitch like that and he certainly did
straight away central he'll get his
sixth home run
indians with two homers in the first
inning cal cuatro will be the northeast
ohio port dealer starting pitcher for
the tribe tonight coming off his fourth
start in pittsburgh where he covered
five scoreless innings giving up three
hits
doing that more than once in the lineup
let's hit to right
and
losing it in the sun
was the right fielder naylor
arise around second and he'll sprint to
third
three and two to donaldson twins trying
to answer in their half of the first big
pop-up down the left-field line
chased by ramirez both ramirez's and it
is jose making the catch here comes a
rise to the plate and he will stall
don't see a lot of those no
oh what a play by bobby bradley
that's out number two in a dynamite
defensive effort robbing alex
kerloff sets up down at the way
and he gets him on strikes
[Applause]
to finish off the strikeout and his
night's work with ronco baldelli coming
out
to bring in griffin jacks with two down
on the second
popped up
straight up in the air
and jeffers
drifting and making the catch and it's a
one two three top of the second inning
three outs and i'll let tito do the rest
high fly ball right field back goes
naylor onto the track he leaps up makes
the catch and hangs on as he went into
the wall and that is a huge out for cal
cuatro nick gordon leading off the twins
third that's hit to the gap in left
center field zimmer won't get there it
stays in the ballpark and gordon glides
into second with an easy stand-up double
[Applause]
chomper to third
and gordon is out at third base
[Applause]
slash toward the gap
simmons rounding second he'll go to
third now the ball kicked to the wall
and simmons will score and arise will
end up at third base again
infield somewhat in and donald takes
care of that
a bullet to center field and the twins
have tied it up
and here is
kirloff carol off lifting it to left and
deep going back is ramirez go on a home
run for alex paralog
take a look at how he stays on this ball
right here
some decent fade to it but head down
stays through this ball immediately knew
it off the bat both outfielders took
about three steps and then they were
kind of shutting it down understanding
that nobody's really getting this
missed up high the indians get their
lead off man aboard and the tying run to
the plate here and hitting number four
and a chopper to third again that one
gets through it's in the hole
and the indians have two on with one out
as bobby bradley pulls into second base
ball four he's loaded the bases and that
is
not good for minnesota
line driving a base hit left field
that's going to score bradley here comes
big harold with the tying run he is safe
and the indians have tied it up austin
hedges with another big clutch hit
second game in a row eddie rosario steps
in
oh boy did you deep right field back is
kepler looking up gone to souvenir city
for eddie rosario and the indians take
back the lead it's six to five cleveland
in the fifth
his sixth home run of the year his first
home run at target field as a visiting
player
and he puts the tribe back on top
and to left down for a hit and the lead
off amazon
[Applause]
ball four and that will send simmons to
second base it looks like frank kona's
out of the dugout and he's gonna pad his
pitcher on the back he's done for the
night we go no batting loves this that
bad
a little pop-up
left field and it drops for a hit and
coming in to score the tying run is
simmons
hesitation by whittgren and gordon as
his second hit sharp grounder up the
middle and with two out we'll see
whether he
thinks of stealing second base
big leg kick and the ball rolled to the
right side hernandez can't crack it
according to third base
and he'll be held there
[Applause]
high drive left center field going back
as zimmer still going back that's off
the wall
a run will score two runs will score a
rise will hold up with a double putting
the twins up by two
see if hansel robles can pick up the
save he is six for eight and save
opportunities he'll face harold ramirez
josh naylor bradley zimmer
there's a long fly ball deep right
center field it is gone a home run and
the indians are not done yet
it's a one-run game as josh naylor hits
his seventh home run of the season
and that snaps a string of 11 indians
retired in a row by the minnesota
bullpen
that's a fair ball past a diving kerala
and digging for second
zimmer to second and he is thrown out a
good throw by kepler in right field
bouncer to shard routine for simmons
a fun night at the ball park and the
twins win it eight to seven